the fundamental narrative about Israel
essentially is that as a compensation
for the Holocaust the Jews were given a
piece of someone else's land in the
Middle East where they've settled and
now there is a battle over that piece of
land because of that original sin if you
like which is uh a Viewpoint that
frankly up until I started listening to
some of your your talks was unshakable
in my really understanding yeah
absolutely I because I don't know I
honestly don't know that's the default
narrative yeah so is in what way is that
not the case Melanie every single thing
that you just said is untrue MH most of
your
conversations that'll make him happy um
obviously it's a big subject but um the
idea that um the Jews had no connection
to the land of Israel until um a
guilt-ridden West uh took them out as a
remnant of the Holocaust and stuck the
into someone else's country is uh the
opposite of the truth so what is the
truth the Jews are the only people for
whom the land of Israel was ever their
National Kingdom hundreds and hundreds
of years before Islam was even invented
and before the Arabs invaded um the Jews
uh were the original Nation the original
Nation upon which America and Britain in
a kind of mystical fashion in Britain
model themselves
why do I say that they were a nation
because they were a
people uh in a particular area of land
which they governed according to laws
they made and which they
defended now um they were uh a nation
for several hundred years under various
Kings um and then uh they were uh
basically kicked out and they they
returned then they kicked out again um
and then the that land of Israel was
occupied by vast numbers of different
civilizations um the
Romans uh uh the Assyrians um uh uh the
uh Arabs uh various various sorts of
Muslims um Christians
crusaders um and for a long period the
ottoman Turks who are Muslim but not
Arab um and then we get to the term of
the last century and there grew up in
Britain as a result of mainly as a
result of Evangelical Christianity a
movement to return the Jews to their
ancestral Homeland um and these people
were called Christian zionists and the
kind of apery of Christian Zionism in
political terms was the balfa
Declaration in 1917 it was a cabinet
which was dominated by Christian
zionists and they beli that it was um uh
their duty to help the Jews return
to Res restore their ancient Homeland um
long story short as you will know after
the first world war the entire Middle
East was carved up between Britain and
France um uh which you know itself was a
questionable uh activity and they
created ni straight lines on the map
well well yes slightly more complicated
than anyway so you know some of these uh
countries that they created you know you
can say that's very questionable
but basically the precursor of the
United Nations which was then the League
of Nations in the 1920s decided that um
as a matter of international treaty
obligation um Britain would be given
custodianship of what was then called
Palestine a name given to it insultingly
by the Romans in order to erase its
Jewish
identity um the British will be given C
custodianship of Palestine called the
Mandate under which Britain would be
under a binding treaty
obligation to return the Jews to their
ancestral Homeland to recreate it now
what was Palestine at the time well bit
of it a very large chunk of it was
promptly given away to the Arabs by
Winston Churchill to become trans Jordan
which is now Jordan so what did that
leave as the territory within which
Britain had a binding Duty undertaken by
the world body of the time to return the
Jews as a matter of historic right what
was that territory it is what is now
Israel what is called the West Bank and
Gaza that is a territory to which the
Jews alone were given the right to
return because they alone had ruled
it terms which have never been abrogated
even though the League of Nations is no
more it gave rise to the United Nations
but the United Nations took on in its
Charter it took on all the obligations
of its predecessor unless they were
specifically abrogated those terms have
never been
abrogated so what then happened was
although the Arabs at the time around
1918 uh King fisel notably and one or
two others they said welcome we welcome
back the Jews to their ancestral
Homeland they used this term because it
was in in their own religion in they
knew this was a Jewish homeland and then
a lot of stuff
happened basically the British having
undertaken in the first place uh this
duty to settle the Jews in their
ancestral Homeland um the Jew the the
the British colonial uh office at the
time and the colonial administrators who
were put into um uh Palestine to
administer this mandate did everything
they could to stop it and they among
other things brought in a an Islamic
fire brand this was at the time when
islamism as we know it political Islam
was growing it was sort of invented
after the first world war and they
brought in the British brought in a
particular Islamic fire brand called
hazamin al- husseini as the grand Muti
of
Jerusalem and he incited he was brought
in to incite revolt and he did there
were then pograms after pograms after
pograms of the returning
Jews um and
uh the thing then blew up into a s of
three-sided War Jews and Arabs and
British or basically at various times
all fighting each other scroll on um the
British threw in the towel gave it over
to the United Nations the United
Stations Britain had Britain by this
time had renaged on its obligation to
settle the Jews in the land Britain had
decided the only way to solve this was
to give a portion of this land to the
Arabs in order to shut them up and stop
them from fighting and in accordance
with that the British closed the gates
of Palestine at the time when the Jews
were starting to be exterminated in
Europe that's what happened and then the
United Nations took over the war
finished the United Nations took over
United Nations said just like Britain
had said right two states two- State
solution one for Jews one for the Arabs
and just as with every on every occasion
since then the Jews said
what you're going to take this away from
us fine fine give us anything anything
cuz we're desperate and the Arabs said
what Jews here never and they
invaded uh or they went to war against
the Jewish homeland there was a What's
called the war of independence which
amazingly the Jews won against all the
odds subsequently there have been I
forgotten how many two three four offers
of of a state of Palestine to the Arabs
which will be made by Israel at every
occasion the Arabs have refused and have
gone to war or have stepped up terrorist
activity against Israelis now before we
go any further into that part of it I
just want to come back to this Homeland
idea this idea that many many centuries
ago certain if we strip away the
identities and we is go many many moons
ago a certain group of people had a
kingdom in this area and after that the
been 10 civilizations or 15
civilizations that have come and lived
in this land and now for some reason
it's it's kind of like isn't it a bit
like me going well I used to you know I
grew up in this flat in Moscow and now I
want to be resettled there and all the
neighbors have agreed to kick out that
guy who lives there now and put me in
that flat instead is it not like that
well no it's not like that first of all
the Jews never left the land they were
always coming back to it um even under
occupation there was always a Jewish
presence in the land and from the mid
19th century onwards there was a Jewish
majority in
Jerusalem um that's the first thing the
second thing was that the land at the
time of the Mandate was very sparsely
populated the people who were there were
mainly nomadic Arabs but they didn't
have an identity they were they consider
themselves to be part of Syria which was
created um or beduin they were they
there was no such thing as Palestinians
Palestinians were the Jews um but there
were people who lived there there were
people who lived there yes and then
because the Jews started coming back um
Arabs started Arabs and others started
pouring in from neighboring Arab lands
and the British uh then let let them
come in even though they were many of
them illegal immigrants they let them
come in because they wanted to stop a
Jewish homeland so it's not a question
of kicking people out um it's a it's
it's and it's not a question of you know
people who had some sort of mystical
attachment to some country you're
talking about the Jewish people who have
been persecuted in virtually every
country in which they've settled no
country ever has ever wanted them apart
from India and China which have never
had a problem with their Jewish
populations but in
Europe no way nobody wanted them um and
it was in respect of that as as well as
the fact that um uh they were the
original nation and have always wanted
to go back um that um they were
considered to have the right to go
back um so so is this kind of Perpetual
persecution what I I'm just trying to
get this logically clear persecution of
Jews in Europe is that what uniquely in
the history of humanity gives Jews the
right to resettle a land in which they
didn't have that much of a presence was
their country but a long time ago well
okay so why do people think that if they
think that it was the Palestinians
country a long time ago that's that
means that they should have it but they
were living there in the 19th century
but they weren't there was no such thing
as the
Palestinians there was no such thing as
the Palestinian people there was no
Palestinian people until it was invented
in the mid 1960s there was these nomadic
Arabs who lived there yeah but they
didn't want to country of Their Own the
Jews were a nation they had a country of
their own and it was taken away from
them and then they were persecuted
around the world and so it seemed only
decent and fair that they should have it
back and a lot of people at the time
thought that was absolutely fine but it
was there was a resistance whipped up
which was basically a religious
resistance in my view um and remains
basically a religious
resistance um because if you look at the
Arab world uh the Muslim World
unfortunately and look at the
Palestinian Arabs and what they are
producing uh day by day in terms of what
they teach their children and the
materials that they put out it's it's
not it's not really accurate just to say
it's anti-israel which indeed it is um
and it's it's certainly the case that
they want in my view and I think this is
proven by what they say and what they do
and they Insignia and their flags and
their materials they want Israel gone
they don't want two states they want
Israel gone but it's much worse than
that what they're producing day by day
is is anti-jewish
Venom um crude conspiratorial Jews are
uniquely the source of evil in the world
that's what they're producing that's
what they're teaching their children uh
to hate
and people in the west just have no idea
of this because it is never ever
reported and so I got into a lot of
difficulty because
um uh until the year 2000 I'd never been
to Israel never wanted to go I thought
as a British Jew I was you know it was
it it was great it was fine it nothing
to do with me and I'd bought into quite
a lot of the stuff that you know we'
been talking about because you know if
if you don't know about the Middle East
why would you think any any different um
and
um uh
in in in 1982 when I was at the guardian
um I was brought up very sharply against
the fact that as a British Jew um I
spoke as a matter of fairness about why
there seemed to be a double standard in
the reporting of Israel at that time as
opposed to reporting of Syria Syria at
that time um had murdered or caused to
be killed um between 15 and
40,000 opponents of President Assad the
father of the president Assad and it was
virtually not reported at the Garden it
was a few paragraphs it was it was
nothing whereas Israel was at war in the
Lebanon and it was a front page story
every day it was Furious editorials it
was outrage Reds and I said why is there
a double
standard and that's when I realized the
racism of the left because I was told um
of course it's a double standard you
don't expect us to uh um uh treat the
developing world like us the developing
world is not brought up as we are to
respect human life consequently we can't
judge them by our standards that's
racism I went what so let let me get
this right if someone's Born Into the
developing world they're not entitled to
the same rights to life and Liberty as
we
are is isn't that racism and they said
why are you so
upset we do you the great honor I became
you like that you we do you the great
honor of assuming that you and Israel
and I became
Israel
um that you and Israel uh adhere to the
same principles as we do respect for
human life so we judge you by our
standards and what's more you tell us
that you are morally Superior to us so
we should judge you by higher standards
and that's when I realized the
anti-Semitism of the left and the racism
of the left and that's when I first
realized that my naive belief that we
were all marching to the same tude
behind the same Banner of decency was
not the case they were on the other side
and then I didn't do any more stuff
about any of that for a long time and
then in the year 2000 when the intera
started second NE as it was called
something very similar happened Israelis
are being blown to bits in pizza parlor
and cafes and um in bomb buses in Israel
and um you know several thousand were
murdered and from the get-go in Britain
um Israel was totally condemned for
taking cine action to stop it and as a
matter of justice and fairness I said
what is this why are you behaving like
this and everybody went oh she's a
Jew she's not properly
British and that was when I realized as
a British Jew you could not support the
Jewish people as a people not allowed um
and that's when I realized something was
very very badly wrong uh with Britain's
attitude to Jews not just to Israel but
to Jews and that but the two were bound
up together uh because Israel was being
presented not least by the BB BC as
basically the Fountain of all evil in
the Middle East it was an aggressive
country it behaved illegally all of this
in my view as I came to believe over
many years subsequently all of it was a
lie but that's what everyone was told
and so consequently if you were a Jew
standing up for all this then of course
you were also evil of course you were
and this was a shattering really
shattering set of developments for me
and eventually kind of long story short
or shorter I came to put all that
together with all the other stuff we're
talking about all the other stuff we're
talking about because it's all to do
with as you said Constantine truth and
lies is basically what it's about when
you pair it all down people are telling
themselves lies about reality they're
living in a world of fantasy which they
purport they they they they they want us
to believe is the reality they tell lies
about other people and that they don't
realize that they lies because there's
no such thing as a lie anymore there's
no such thing as truth everything is a
matter of opinion everything is a matter
of
opinion